ich
überhaupt keinen bock auf dieses spiel
denn das hier meine lieben freunde ist
das world hades
das hier ist das world hades game und
ich habe dieses spiel bereits schon mal
auf meinem kanal gespielt und diesmal
werde ich es wieder probieren das ganze
zu schaffen das ist schon ein bisschen
länger her allerdings glaube ich dass
ich heute wirklich gute chancen
wir haben schon zwei von 30 levels durch
wir müssen wir durch den kreis durch um
das ding zu holen und dann wieder durch
die lücke durch bewege ich
grassiert wollte komplett viele von euch
werden sich wahrscheinlich warum
viele von euch werden sich
wahrscheinlich überhaupt nicht mehr
daran erinnern können dass ich
viele von euch wissen wahrscheinlich gar
nicht dass ich diese spieler gespielt
habe allerdings wenn wir uns jetzt ganz
schnell bereit
ich es sprachen lernen es ist schon
jahre her dass ich dieses spiel hier
gespielt habe allerdings habe ich immer
noch eine rechnung offen mit diesem
ganzen spiel also wir gucken dass wir
hier irgendwie durchkommen jetzt
wieder
[Musik]
okay okay
und jetzt ein weiter weg und jetzt
wieder ein weiter sehr gut
und jetzt hier ein sehr gut okay wir
haben die nächsten checkpoint und weiter
geht es keine möglichkeit vorteil schön
weiter geht es auch hier und hier runter
und hier um die ecke
und ein hör- und jetzt rein hier sehr
gut
ist alles in butter hier vorne erst mal
in die lücke ganz entspannt jetzt hier
in die lücke jetzt hier vorne den können
wir direkt mitnehmen jetzt hier weiter
einfach selbstbewusstsein luca hier zack
rein das kriegen wir hier den kriegen
wir hin den kriegen wir hin und jetzt
hier in die mitte
hier drehen sich jetzt eine menge sachen
und wir haben nur einen checkpoint also
hier rein hier
hier vorn lang jetzt hier weiter lang
hier weiter lang hier weiter lang runter
und sagt wir sind beim checkpoint jetzt
müssen wir allerdings immer eine runde
gehen ist allerdings kein problem zack
und weiter geht's sagt zack zack zack
zack
okay hier zwischen können wir auch schon
weiter geht's weiter geht's weiter
geht's keinem in die stadt vortäuschen
um ein nein die
ok
erstmal den hier holen und jetzt hier
außen wieder ganz entspannt den weg lang
und dann können wir hier direkt weiter
um die linie kurz abholen und dann gehe
ich erst mal so hoch
ich hab' ich habe eine idee ich hole
erst die ganzen gelben teile und werde
mich dann noch mal zurück bewegen zu
meinem checkpoint hier einmal lang jetzt
hier zack zack zack
jetzt hier vorne rum und jack hier ein
nur noch den ganz letzten gelben holen
[Musik]
konzentration ist das a und o luca das
hat schon jesus damals gesagt
[Musik]
eine stunde später
wird geschichte geschrieben
es wird heute keine
sorge luca ist quasi genau das gleiche
wie das zweite level
wir gehen also hier jetzt erstmal ganz
schnell runter
[Musik]
ich war grad duschen ich könnte direkt
wieder den zwei stunden später
huhu fischers tritt frischen fische aber
ich versteh besseren fische das hier
sieht todes isenburg
warum kommt er plötzlich eine freundin
der von unten ist jetzt hier deswegen
kann ich jetzt hier erst mal kurz warten
und jetzt hier mit ihm hier lang
rübergehen perfekt perfekt perfekt
perfekt perfekt warten bis der blaue
rechts ist super perfekt perfekt perfekt
perfekt perfekt ok die taktik ist auf
jeden fall auf gehört ganz schnell ganz
schnell ganz schnell ok den hamburg bei
dem anderen willst du auch schon wie es
geklappt hat da muss ich jetzt nicht
warten bis der da vorne rechts ist super
super super das hat nicht geklappt das
nicht
[Musik]
ich habe noch gläser hier
wie soll ich denn da lang ich muss immer
wieder von vorne starten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hier ist meine damen herren besitz der
könig um noch zwei stück das kann ja
nicht so schwer denn
nach zwei stück nur zwei stücken kann
[Musik]
ich sagen
dass ich sie ganz sicher
[Musik]
ich bin so ein trottel aber das ist mein
weg leute ich sag's euch hier einmal
vorne lang jetzt hier land vorne jetzt
hier vorne abwarten da muss ich jetzt
nämlich ganz easy einfach nur wenn der
da vorne auf dem grauen ist nämlich
genau jetzt einmal zack und jetzt werde
auf dem weißen ist also tag und da bin
ich
ich dachte mir einfach gesetzt da unten
rechts muss sich jetzt auf das gelbe
ding holen das hier ist relativ easy das
mache ich wenn auf dem weiß ist so
steht schon wieder
[Musik]
sehr gut sehr gut
scheiße
ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho besitzer der
weihnachtsmann kommt schon luca es ist
nicht schwer es ist nicht schwer kräftig
straft ich würd sich gut
okay dann haben wir den hammer den
hammer der minister nicht sagen okay ich
hier
ansetzen
[Musik]
nach vorne ist
letzter letzten match am kopf die habe
ich den nach oben gemacht ich bin oben
lange laufen oben an ok easy peasy
plätze in parks
alles umsonst
vertrieblich konzert